so
um our first speaker now is limo gorchen
she's done her undergrad in harvard in
computer science
um and now she's a phd student in
machine learning and causal inference
at the computer science department at
the university of oxford
and at the alan turing institute she
is currently very much interested in
causal inc in
life causal inference um in the service
of responsible
ml but before that she has done a lot of
work
in nfp and she's gonna talk with us
about one of the hair projects in this
field
um so anymore the screen is yours
yes um so hi everyone i'm gonna share my
slides
and hopefully you will be able to see
them very soon
can everyone see my slides great
let me know if there are any issues with
that and please help me with the chat
because i currently cannot
see it unless i okay now i can see it
good
um right so yeah i just wanted to start
by saying that
i'm going to talk about a previous
project that i did as mentioned so it's
been
over a year uh since that so please feel
free to tackle me and i'll try
my best to answer all your questions
about the small details
but also if you're interested in
chatting about some more recent stuff
that i'm
working on and methodological causal
inference for all sorts of applications
i would be
interested to discuss that as well later
on but let's start
with uh this particular project that was
part of a summer internship
that i did where i was working
with a research team at ibm and
we were interested in particularly
extracting all sorts of information from
pdf documents
obviously their clients have access to
various documents
however it's sometimes hard to get
exactly you know there's a lot of data
out there about how to make it useful is
actually kind of a challenging question
um so we were in particularly uh looking
at how to handle table data
and how to connect that to a text
summarization
actually uh and the solution we came up
with relied on bert
which i hear a lot of people here
actually had recent experience with
um so we can discuss that as well
so the problem definition to start with
was
essentially um as i mentioned looking at
pdf documents looking at tables
tables um have a lot of information in
them most of the quantitative
information that we could actually
use as machine learning researchers
would come from
all sorts of tables however if they are
devoid of context
which is what most let's say ocr or
document extraction algorithms would
currently do they could
identify and extract tables quite well
but
they would be devoid of context mostly
so the question was how to integrate
context from the rest of the document
into tables both as we store the
information
but also as we would like let's say
to present it to users so for example
google
recently i don't know if it's currently
on or off but they had a beta product
for table search which makes a lot of
sense people are interested in
information
interested in quantitative information
those are summarizing tables and you
might want to
know something about text returns uh
let's say of specific uh famous people
at a particular
time um that will need to be stored
along
alongside some kind of informative um
title
and ideally also presented to people
with an informative title
so let's just get a flavor of that
by looking at an example so as we saw in
the previous slide
if we just look at the table in
separation from the rest of the document
we might
not really know what it deals with we
know it's about computer science we know
it might relate to some other fields it
might relate to
students because concentrators kind of
sounds like people are concentrating in
that
topic and the year but we don't really
know where it's coming from
or what exactly the content is so sorry
once we start putting it together with
titles that might exist
in different hierarchies in a document
we would get
a much better sense or an exact sense of
what the table
uh is talking about and so
we could just paste those together and
let the user do the rest of the work but
that would not be the most elegant of
solutions
so the idea was to try and automatically
come up with those
titles from the context that exists in
the rest of the document
more some documents are more structured
than others
and in particular we looked at the case
study of scientific papers because we
wanted to get
a beta product out or some kind of proof
of concept out
um yeah i wouldn't say i i was not this
was from the research angle of things
not necessarily from the product
development of things
but in particular scientific papers
offered us
the opportunity to look at many open
sourced
documents we wouldn't have to deal with
any particular clients
you know obligations and legal issues
and from that we wanted to get a sense
of
how how would we come up with these
titles
and how would we structure a data set
to even answer this type of question so
just to give you a flavor of what that
would look like
again if we just have a table devoid of
context
it's a little hard to tell what it's
talking about
a nice thing about scientific papers of
course was that they also
will always be labeled it's a very clean
data set in that regard
which you wouldn't necessarily get from
pdf documents from
random clients uh it really depends some
of them also have like
a pre-existing template that
would uh give a domain expert some
knowledge about what the
table would talk about but then they
wouldn't label it
as nicely so the existence of these
titles
in the scientific papers really gave us
essentially labels
we already knew what the target would be
of trying to generate
um some kind of uh of a title and we
would also be able to score ourselves
based to some
ground truth right so
that conceptually reminded us of
summarization which is a known problem
in nlp
tasks um that would usually
um go into two buckets two categories
there would be
an extractive approach to summarization
and an abstractive approach to
summarization
the extractive one as you see let's say
in this
doodle would literally just highlight
sentences key sentences or key phrases
from the document
piece them together and feed that to the
user as a title
obstructive summarization would try to
take that one step further perhaps
depends on the application and actually
generate text
that is also grammatically correct or
[Music]
is self-contained so we were
particularly interested in abstractive
summarization in this case
and just to say a few more words about
that the usual use case
where most of these approaches to
summarization existing approaches to
summarization
would be tested in corpuses of very
short articles
um usually news articles there's like a
benchmark data set on cnn and daily mail
news pieces and the um
the task would be to come up with three
sentences uh three short sentences
something like bullet points at the
beginning of news articles
that would appear let's say i believe
still on the cnn website
um and so to
address a challenge like that um common
uh ways to to either let's say achieve
extractive first
uh would be to use something like text
rank some kind of
svd decomposition of the matrix bayesian
approaches
and so forth and that would rely very
heavily on just the frequency of the
appearance of
specific words in the sentence or the
document level
the obstructive approaches would usually
lead us to sequence to sequence
models pointer generator networks and
more recently two transformers which i
also hear
a lot of people here have interest in
and experience with and for a good
reason
uh those are very useful in general
um so yeah i'm already gonna give you
uh i mean you know that we're gonna use
bird so we're gonna use transformers
but just to give us again a flavor of
what the usual task would look like
it would be some some form of a news
article like this one
very short which again makes the task a
little easier than what we're trying to
achieve because if we're trying to do um
across uh let's say cross object
the cross domains of scientific domains
uh
summarization in order to come up with
uh
titles for specific tables within
sections of the document where the
document is quite complex and long
we're already talking about a different
nature of a problem
and obviously we would like a single
title so we don't really have as much
slack
if we'd like in our predictions because
it's not like oh you can get two of the
three sentences right or something like
that
right so uh one previous work that we
encountered and i thought might be
interested to some people with their own
problems i'm going to mention it as well
is this paper from a team at google
i assume this was related to their own
search engine for tables um
that i mentioned before they were also
looking at how to generate titles but
they were specifically interested in web
tables now web tables would have this
nice property where
the page would usually be very well
structured and very well titled right
you would
literally have headers in the html to
rely on
and just piecing those together usually
would already give you quite a good
result
however in this particular
paper where they looked at a lot of
information that only google would have
so that was really nice they had a huge
data set
of people's queries and they
ended up using a pointer generator
network
solution i assume that if they would
were to repeat this today they would
have gone with a more transformer style
network but this is already um
quite similar let's say at least in the
attention element of it
um and that was very nice for their own
purposes for our purposes of course we
would have
much smaller corpuses and
also again our generation
challenge would be much harder in the
sense that we're not going to have these
very nice structured titles to just
piece together
we're interested in both an attractive
summarization that makes sense to users
on its own but also that you'll have to
piece together from
full sentences
right so once again to give you a sense
of what the
data set we ended up compiling looked
like
so the tables themselves would be quite
more complicated than wikipedia ones
which were the usual use case in the
google paper
and you would have some kind of a label
uh given by the actual authors of the
paper which would be the the
title or the caption that they gave for
the table depends on the format of the
paper
um sometimes it would be quite long
which is another challenge
um and you would usually also have
a linking text or a linking paragraph as
we called it sometimes it would be one
paragraph sometimes it would be longer
it really depends but the idea was that
we wanted a mechanism to
first of all find the references to the
table name
across the document and then use those
as a specific
training data we're interested in for
each table such that we don't have to
analyze
the full uh document even though we
experimented with different settings of
that as well
obviously um you can think of it as like
another
hyperparameter choice of like how much
of the text you want your
model to see and to rely on and we also
really were interested in
mixtures of of topics
of domain expertise and we also noticed
that a lot of
what were perceived to be good titles by
let's say at least the team we were
working with at the time
uh seemed to follow these very specific
patterns
so you could almost be tempted and i
think some of the people that i worked
with were actually tempted
to take a very hands-on approach and
just say
how about we just do something very
similar to regular expression or we
start with some kind of a
pattern matching particular people who
came from more
traditional information retrieval
backgrounds
we explored that for a while but i think
part of uh
the takeaway of this talk was actually
that the performance once we
started using a fine tuning on top of
bert
were actually so good without having to
do all this cleaning and very specific
uh specification of uh of patterns or
trying to fill in
you know position tags uh based on our
own
um specific data was actually more
useful
so diving even deeper
into the pipeline that we ended up
implementing
right around the time that we started
working on it actually there was a new
emnlp paper that came out which was
specifically using bert for text
summarization
both for extractive and abstractive
as you can see here i even reproduced
some of their very nice results
i assume there are more updated versions
of this result
even because it's been a year but
at the time that seemed to be a very
cool approach
so essentially what they did was take a
very similar
i mean fake bird obviously and they take
a very similar structure
um aside for uh the separation tokens
so um their uh hypothesis
was that actually separating out each
sentence
more strongly or more explicitly
from each other instead of treating it
as as a as an entire single
sequence would be a better approach in
this case because
they started with an extractive approach
and they said okay there would be
sentences that were
would be completely irrelevant uh for
the
um title we're trying to get to um
so actually the first
step in this process would actually be
to eliminate the sentences that we're
not interested in
so they wanted to have a stronger
division between the sentences and be
able to
sort of um get rid of some of those more
quickly instead of retaining the context
from the entire
sentence and then again i don't know how
many are familiar so i'm just going to
repeat essentially there's going to be a
summarization
over three types of embeddings there's
going to be an individual token
embedding there's going to be a segment
embedding
and a position embedding within the
sentence these are all going to be
summed up together
i'm going to be fed into they
experimented with different
depths of transformer networks
and and come up with vectors at the
other end of it that you could use for
your subsequent uh predictions whatever
they might be
so uh yeah the idea was that we
um we didn't want to repeat the work
essentially so we ended up using their
release implementation that all of you
could use as well so
both this paper is available online of
course but the
github code as well and they release
their pre-training
so a few words about bert again uh i
guess a lot of you are familiar with
this already
but i'm just going to repeat this
quickly um
it comes through uh this whole tradition
of um different transformer
models um the difference between let's
say the very first generation if we'd
like of elmo
then gpt than bert would be the way that
different elements in the sentence
relate to each other
essentially whether um it's a
bi-directional approach
where all nodes in the network are
connected to each other
um gpt the original one was the left to
right
structure where the left is connected to
the right and so forth
and um elmo was a completely separate
independent sets of weights for the left
direction and for the right direction
also elmo was not a fine-tuning approach
but rather a feature
generation approach which
yeah has it's mostly cons but
yeah again a lot of this has also been
updated since
you might all be familiar with gpt3
that i'm sure is no longer left to right
um
so some of this have been is obviously
work in progress but
uh bert i heard one uh one nlp expert
recently referred to this as uh he's
counting time in terms of birth years
so now we're burke plus plus two or
three
um so yeah that's that's how fundamental
in nlp it has been
um and the fact that it is widely
available for use
also made it very popular
and uh one of its main selling points is
that you can fine-tune it
for many different original tasks it was
also trained
through various tasks including
sentence fair classification single
sentence classification
tagging tasks question answering tasks
and so forth
and then the idea is that given the
weights that were trained to do all
these
different tasks you could also fine-tune
it for your own particular use so in our
case let's say we have a very small data
set
it would be completely infeasible to go
and train any kind of deep network
honestly but definitely nothing of this
scale
with any of the data that we had but the
the main power of it
is that you can leverage even a very
small data set
in order to tune some kind of behavior
that was already acquired
in a much larger dataset
and back to the idea behind
the summarization flavor of birds that
we were using
so as i said they relied both on an
extractive element and then an
abstractive um element that was actually
a continuous uh training approach so for
the extractive i just wanted to give you
a sense of it
but um again don't get too hung up on
this you're welcome to read the
original paper um the idea was that
um pretty simply as you can imagine
um there are the different layers those
are marked as
hl l is the depth of the
layer that you're currently in um you're
going to get
some prediction from a feed forward
network
plus some let's say the elements from
burke that were already there
for the particular input that you have
you pass it through a layer norm
and then essentially you combine it
again with multi-head attention
to get the prediction from each layer
eventually you're going to get the
output from the last
layer capital l here
and you're going to pretty you know
simply put a sigmoid on top of it as you
would do with any other
network pretty much with some bias get
your output binary classification
entropy
as you would expect for a classification
task like an extractive summarization
and um you get your um
your output that you were interested in
for the abstractive case
there was a slightly more complicated
use of some of the weights that were
already trained in the extractive case
with a six layer transformer that was
initialized randomly first
they did some label smoothing which also
um
that also sorry i just saw something in
the chat but um
there was also a present in the google
paper that i mentioned
with the pointer generator framework
and they also allowed some slack in the
kl divergence and i assume that is
because
that gave them better results for the
abstractive element of it
um then they optimized the encoder and
the decoder
separately for what they claimed would
be enhanced ability
i actually don't didn't
experiment with that myself and then
finally
they had a subword tokenization that
handled
out of vocabulary issues quite well
which is another sort of usual concern
with obstructive
abstractive solutions so
yeah i'm just close to wrapping up if
people don't have questions
but i just wanted to give you an
overview of uh
of what was the journey uh that we went
on
once we aligned on this solution to the
problem
so we started with uh bert
in its self-drained form um
that uh of course as people who used it
know is based on wikipedia
and has uh many many uh billions of
words uh um as part of its training and
a book corps course of um 800 million
words
um then on top of that we
took some um advantage of a work that
came out
uh at the same time as we were working
on this
that already did fine-tuning of bert for
both extractive and obstructive
summarization their
data set was the benchmark one for
summarization tests which was the cnn
daily mail
and they also added to it some new york
times and another
smaller data set called exum and they
ended up with something like 500k
documents that were labeled and clean
which is also a pretty decently sized
training set um and
we used in particular their abstractive
weights
and we fine-tuned on top of that with
something like 1.5
k documents if my
internship would have lasted longer i
would probably try to get a hold of more
papers but i guess the main takeaway of
this talk is was actually
we got some pretty good results with a
data set that was that small
so my uh the main
point that i want to deliver is that if
you go with a fine-tuning approach
you could actually leverage
the somewhat small data sets that you
might be interested in that are very
specific
and very curated and very um maybe
uh specific to your to your needs uh but
actually
leverage all the you know power both
computation and data wise of of bigger
players
in the field and we ended up with table
titles which is
what we wanted to get out so
yeah just to um
list this explicitly uh the takeaways
that i think
at least i had from this project was was
that deep nets are very very good at
dealing with noise
so this data set was noisy uh
and one approach that we tried at the
beginning was
to try and clean them and also come up
with labels that were exactly
you know of the patterns that i showed
you before and try to really
pay a lot of attention to data cleaning
and to
labeling and to a lot of manual work
maybe you know you can automate some of
it but the point is that it wasn't
actually necessary
and i think the people in the team that
had led less experience with
deep learning were a little skeptical of
that at first so
um just to point it out there
a small data set is not necessarily
detrimental uh
obviously it would be better to work
with bigger ones it's
probably always better uh when you're
dealing with with deeper networks but
the point is that fine tuning could
really help you leverage even small
corpuses
one particular thing to keep in mind is
that if you're moving from a very
you know a model that was that is
gigantic and was trained on
uh very big data sets pay attention to
not over
fit and to early stop and to have proper
tests of how your training is going
because it's
hard to forget if you're used to
training
other types of models and
finally this is more specific to text
summary
the usual metrics that are used are root
scores and blouse scores
um those are good but they were designed
for extractive summaries
which makes a lot of sense uh because if
you're trying to compute something about
the frequency of
uh let's say word usage or how many of
them did you
how many in the label appeared correctly
in the prediction
that would give you a very good result
uh in the extractive case in the
abstractive case the whole point is that
you want
your model to generate something more
interesting to give it some slack in the
kl divergence for example
um but that could lead the the score
straight i would say
these are still useful as a ballpark so
don't throw them out the window
but be mindful that even if that's the
metric that's used
it doesn't mean that it's perfect it's
just the sort of
compromise that we have so
that's all for me uh do people have any
questions
okay um thank you very much
limo for this very nice and clear talk
um
yeah so i i see one question about repo
in code i will just say that
unfortunately it is proprietary because
i was working with company
so i cannot share that publicly at this
time uh
but the nice thing is that uh the tech
summarization
bert uh pre-training approach so forth
is available
um from the leo at all paper i can even
paste
the link if that's helpful for people
also i could share my slides if people
are interested later
but i will do that just in case
they also have a github repo with uh
with everything
yes uh we also have almost so
we have almost 50 people in our um
zoo meeting and we also have almost 50
people
viewers on youtube but um
everyone seems to be a bit shy today
that's okay we can also talk about you
know anything else
if people are interested in
fairness i'm happy to talk about
fairness happy to talk about causal
inference happy to talk about
um there is
um two two questions coming up
in in the chat um
first is can you more specific about
your talk can you tell more about
evaluation that was conducted for the
experiment yeah so as i was saying um
it was first of all i think that with
these types of tasks honestly
the best evaluation would be a user
study
i don't think there is a better way
particularly with abstractive
text summarization it is a bit um
up to i mean you could uh score it
again with something like blau or like
rouge um
leo at all in particular as you can see
in their
github repo for the paper they do
exactly give those scores because
that's kind of the the way to benchmark
um
your results so um we also did that we
achieved
scores that were somewhat similar to the
original paper if i remember correctly
[Music]
and
[Music]
yeah so so that is one way to go we
wanted to conduct a user study i believe
that the team that i worked with
continued to conduct one in the google
paper
this one that i mentioned before
they did do a user study and then you
can of course
get more creative in terms of ranking
let's say an average of people's
responses where
you use some kind of la carte scale or
something like that
and you ask both for relevance and for
style
and for let's say grammar or something
like that
and then you can get you know a more
holistic view
of how well your um your performance is
of course we also eyeballed our own
results we
showed it you know kind of stress tested
through our own team
tried to generate it on different
domains and so forth
and it all behaved quite well
yeah so those are the approaches we took
i'm sure there might be
others available out there but i think
these are good starting points
another question is regarding the
birth maximum token and have you
did you need to kind of tackle this
and to summarize tax that are longer
than the 512 tokens
that's a very good question um so
i think at first we did try that it has
been a while so i don't want to mislead
anyone
it's possible that since we ended up
using
linking text as i said we did a regular
expression matching
to find references to the tables to each
table that we
were looking for at a time we ended up
with sentences that were
um i mean we ended up with full
paragraphs so
often we would have something like three
paragraphs or something like that
whether it was above 512 tokens or not
i actually don't remember but my guess
is that actually the
leo at all paper uh would give an answer
to that as well
and i assume you only had texts in
english
in the project
in this particular one we didn't but um
so you did have
also um so do you have that's a question
from the chat of do you have experience
of abstractive summarization in other
languages
yeah so so i personally don't i know
that german
usually is quite good at that uh
compared to other languages
so i would be hopeful that by now uh
there would be
something around that but i don't have
personal experience with it
yeah so sorry what i was trying to say
before was that we only worked with
english today
and also more general about someone
asked before about
birth if you have any
experience with word for text clustering
or topic modeling
it's a good question first of all it
sounds like in this group there are
already quite
a few people who worked with it so you
might have different views
i only used it for supervised tasks
honestly uh
it sounds like what you're describing is
an unsupervised task
um but it's possible that people have
yeah approaches to deal with that
um yeah if anyone would like to share
their experience we'd
bear with non-supervised tests
um feel free to jump in i
i did some hacky project on it where
i used the bird embedding and then
project he
projected with umap
that was quite interesting so i was
working with newspaper
news articles and basically we had many
languages
and so i was really able to separate
like having really big cluster depending
on the language
and also kind of similar things in the
in the thing of the language and part of
it was more about football other part
was about something else that was quite
interesting
but sadly i don't have anything to share
here but that
that worked quite well so that's a good
way to go
yeah but it's a very good point that at
the end of the day you are generating
vectors
so you could kind of get creative about
it
almost in similar ways as you would with
a word embedding so it
depends
[Music]
um how did you
um share the
reason for your sling being shared
um um
and maybe one last question um
yeah there are resources um shared in
the chat
if anyone is interested with different
birth applications
and maybe you can say last question
would be the
um the compute costs to generate the
model so actually it wasn't too bad
because pre-trained
weights were already available if you
have to train these
yourself um it would be much much worse
uh
obviously an access to a gpu of sorts
would uh be required but aside for that
it doesn't have to be anything nasty it
depends on your own sort of
yeah the the data you're dealing with
but um yeah but once you have
pre-trained
uh access to pre-trained weights it's
actually not um
not that terrible at all on someone is
on youtube is mentioning the
very big memory consumption
uh but you didn't encounter that i
assume
nope not working and also yeah um i
think they also mentioned it
specifically for
model which um i guess was not used in
this project
um okay so thank you very very much limo
it was lovely
to have you here with this wonderful
background
and we will share your slides also
sounds like it yeah should i share it
here should i send it to you what's
better um
please send it to me and i will post it
in the meetup